this is the last day of the supreme
court's term and the last day on the
court for justice stephen breyer appeals
court judge katanji brown jackson will
be sworn in later today to replace him
after the high court issues its final
decisions and orders jan crawford is
outside the supreme court on this
historic day jan good morning to you i
cannot imagine how katanji brown jackson
must be feeling as she's waking up this
morning what does this mean for the
future of the court
well i mean it means after weeks of
those controversial rulings today
there's going to be another historic
change because after 28 years on the
court justice stephen breyer is stepping
down turning his seat over to his former
law clerk judge katanji brown jackson
who will be sworn in at noon today and
make history as the first black female
justice ever to serve on the supreme
court now breyer who at 83 years old is
the court's oldest justice sent
president biden a letter yesterday
saying it has quote been my great honor
to participate as a judge in the effort
to maintain our constitution and the
rule of law but this will not change the
balance of the court it still has six
conservative justices three liberals
jackson like briar expected to be a
reliable liberal vote but you know she
is certain to have an impact the court
on the law and and really as a role
model for young women and girls and of
course she is stepping into a deeply
divided court last week over turning roe
versus wade and ruling in a more
conservative direction in other cases
from guns
to school prayer and then the court
wrapping up its term this morning with
more decisions that could have
wide-ranging implications on climate
change and immigration nate
jan thank you